und heute in wiesbaden erreiche ich den
politikwissenschaftler emanuel richter
hallo
also für meinungsforscher auf der einen
seite und für politikwissenschaftler auf
der anderen seite ist das doch ein fest
im moment man es gibt alle paar tage
neue umfragen es gibt alle paar tage
neue zahlen und es gibt faszinierende
veränderungen in der zahlen landschaft
in den letzten monaten stand heute für
wie wahrscheinlich würden sie denn die
einzig denkbare zweierkoalition halten
zwischen spd und cdu
also wenn sie mich so direkt fragen
würde sagen für gänzlich
unwahrscheinlich weil das ja ein bündnis
ist was bislang an der macht gewesen ist
und wo alle alle beteiligten von einer
erneuerung reden von irgendeinem
neuanfang auch die cdu also insofern ist
das ganz unwahrscheinlich aber sie haben
es ja eben schon den beitrag gezeigt
wenn man sich mal überlegt welche
koalition möglich sind dann ist das gar
nicht so einfach und insofern wird es
nicht nur bis zur bundestagswahl
spannend sondern eigentlich besonders
spannend dann nochmal danach wer kann
wer will mit wem koalieren und es wird
ja auch er vermutlich auf ein
dreierbündnis hinauslaufen oder gibt es
ja ein paar möglichkeiten ja schön dann
können wir jetzt die nächsten monate
über die möglichen dreier bündnisse
sprechen welches halten sie denn für am
ehesten wahrscheinlich na ja das wird
sicherlich ganz stark davon beeinflusst
werden wer stärkste partei wird und wer
eben dann gewissermaßen die anwartschaft
auf die kanzlerschaft er wird das ist ja
traditionell der kandidat die kandidatin
mit den stärksten stimmenanteilen der
partei und insofern denke ich hat scholz
relativ gute chancen in diese position
zu kommen gewissermaßen der gekürte
kanzlerkandidat zu sein der dann
koalitionsverhandlungen als erster
führen kannst kann aber auch sein dass
diese koalitionsverhandlungen scheitern
und das ist ganz stark abhängig vom
verhalten der fdp die sich in den
letzten tagen fand ich sehr interessant
da auch noch mal so ein bisschen zurück
genommen hat und gesagt hat na ja wir
schließen jetzt sozusagen link eine
beteiligung an der linken koalition oder
an anderen links liberalen koalition
nicht gänzlich aus aber wir stellen
bedingungen also da ist noch viel
bewegung und ich würde in der tat
vermuten dass nach der bundestagswahl da
nochmal ergebnis mehr bewegung
hineinkommt in die frage wer kann wer
will mit wem dann spätestens übermorgen
wird die fdp sich ja nicht mehr so
richtig zurückhalten können glauben sie
dass man da was erfahren wird am sonntag
ich glaube nicht also das ist ja die
strategie von herrn lindner gewesen
zunächst einmal zu sagen sie haben
gewisse aversion gegen eine beteiligung
der linken das wollen wir nicht aber
wenn es dann um die frage geht können
wir mit rot grün dann wird das
sicherlich da noch mal auch mit seiner
partei sprechen müssen und es kommt ja
nicht nur auf seine individuelle
position an sondern auf das verhalten
der partei aber ich denke jetzt auch auf
dem fdp parteitag wird es keine klare
aussage geben das wäre auch strategisch
sehr sehr unklug denn die fdp ist in der
tat so was wie der königsmacher und die
muss ich ihre option natürlich offen
halten wir haben ja vorher auch ganz
kurz über mecklenburg vorpommern und
über berlin gesprochen lassen sie uns
über diese beiden landtagswahlen auch
regens war die ursprünglich eigentlich
sollten es drei sein aber in thüringen
wird ja doch keiner sein zu berlin wie
glauben sie kommt frau gefallen da durch
naja bislang erstaunlich gut denken wir
zurück es war ja erstens viel kritik
laut geworden an dieser koalition in
berlin wo er die linke übrigens
beteiligt war und es ist zweitens viel
kritik laut geworden an der person
gefeilt die ja eben durch auch so ein
paar schwierigkeiten
lavieren musste also dass es
insbesondere natürlich die
zurückgezogene promotion die
plagiatsvorwürfe ja die sie bis hin zu
ihrer master oder magisterarbeit
erstreckten also sie hatte da keinen
leichten stand scheint aber im land sehr
gut zu punkten also kommt als person gut
an und wir haben ja gerade die zahlen
gesehen also es wäre durchaus möglich
dass sind weiterhin eine von der spd
geführte koalition in berlin regiert und
in schwerin wie sieht's aus dem
mecklenburg vorpommern
noch solider aus der sicht der spd also
ich denke da wäre es auch möglich dass
eben manuela schwesig dort wieder als
favoritin und siegerin aus der wahl
hervorgeht und das ist natürlich
insgesamt bundesweit eine unglaublich
interessante und spannende entwicklung
denn diese dieser deadlock würde man
sagen bei politologen also dieses
verharrende spd bei 14 15 prozent das
ist an vielen stellen mittlerweile
aufgebrochen und da ist also auch dann
in hinblick auf andere parteien ganz
viel bewegung reingekommen also sie
haben es ja eingangs gesagt diese
bundestagswahl ist enorm spannend
ganz viel bewegung reingekommen sagt der
politikwissenschaftler emanuel richter
vielen dank dafür gerne